thank you
I'm very very happy to be here can you
hear me
if you can't hear me raise your hand
I'm really happy to be here
um it's uh
although I've never been here before it
feels like uh almost like a homecoming
because of um the incredible role
at this institution played during
covid-19 where it was the only College
left in the country that really stood up
for freedom
and you know with this college was
established in 1844 or
um abolitionists were despised by the
vast majority of 90 of the people in our
country uh hated them and thought they
were crazy and that a um you know
they're that they were unrealistic and
it wasn't really until three years in
the Civil War that
that um that it flipped and that you
know the president came out and freed
the slaves and he couldn't do it um
because the just the public uh antipathy
or abolitionism so
um it's really this institution has an
extraordinary history and it's been very
very faithful
to the values upon which it was
established which is his love of freedom
no matter what public opinion no matter
what the public cost
no matter who pressures you to stop but
to stand up for it and it's really a
testimony to something special and
the investment that has been made here
not in building a bio teaching students
to build a pile for themselves like most
colleges and whoever dies
with the most off wins
but instead a building character
and demonstrating character and oh thank
you
um I'm going to somebody last I
asked me about how I I got into the you
know the anti-vaxx racket
um and
which I'm not anti-vaccine
although
um I'm kind of a poster child for any
facts movement
um but I I'm you know I I've been an
environmental attorney for now 40 years
up until 2005. that's all I did and then
of that year I I ran in a group called
Hudson River Keeper
which I represented for 40 years
commercial fishermen on the Hudson a
recreational fishermen suing polluters
who were destroying their livelihoods
their property values their communities
and
and they had a business model we have
the oldest commercial fishery and with
the country and the Hudson
the people I represented for 40 years
many of them came from families that
have been fishing the river continuously
since Dutch colonial times it's a
traditional gear Fishery they use the
same fishing methods that were taught by
the Algonquin Indian's original Dutch
settlers New Amsterdam and then passed
down through the generations
um and they had a business model that
worked for three centuries
and then they were put out of business
by polluters who had political clout
and who were able to manipulate
government agencies capture and
manipulate government agencies in order
to escape the discipline of the free
market and force the public to pay their
production costs
and they had turned the Hudson Valley
into kind of a not-free market
capitalism but corporate crony
capitalism
and this corporate kleptocracy
which really is about socialism for the
rich in a very Savage and brutal and
merciless
brand of capitalism for the poor
and they saw this happening
and you know I fought for them for 40
years but in 2000 but ours we were
successful I I brought over
300 successful lawsuits on the Hudson
uh the year 2000 we had forced polluters
to spend three and a half billion
dollars remediating the river
the river when I started working there
caught fire it turned colors depending
on what color they were painting the
trucks at the GM plant in Tarrytown it
was dead water zero dissolved oxygen for
20 miles north of the city 20 miles
south
um today it's the it is an international
model for ecosystem protection it's the
richest waterway in the North Atlantic
it produces more pounds of fish per acre
more biomass per gallon than any other
waterway in the Atlantic Ocean or the
Equator it's the last major river system
left in that in uh Atlantic it still has
strong spawning stocks of all of its
historical species of migratory fish
and the miraculous resurrection of the
Hudson inspired River Keepers on
waterways all over the world we became
the biggest water protection group in
the world we have 350 water Keepers each
one has a patrol boat they each Patrol a
local Waterway and they litigate against
polluters and we're a law enforcement
organization we have great environmental
laws but because of agency capture
they're almost never enforced
and so we're allowed to enforce them
under you know a provision called The
Citizen supervision
in
the National Academy of Sciences
published a report that showed that
every freshwater fish in North America
10-year study
was had was contaminated with dangerous
levels of Mercury
and so the water Keepers who represent
fishermen or particularly
um you know this seemed to us like we
were living in a science fiction
nightmare
were my children not the children of
every other American could now no longer
engage in the Seminole Primal activity
of American Youth which is to go fishing
in the local Waterway and then come home
and safely eat the fish
and
those companies had privatized
the public comments a resource that is
owned by the public
to make profits for themselves they had
privatized they we no longer own the
fish
you know the companies who are doing
that polluter which is coal burning
power plants and cement Kilns primarily
so
um in 2005 we started suing a lot of
people were suing coal plants but we
were suing them the water Keepers were
selling them on Mercury
and I had 40 suits going by 2005. and I
was traveling all around the country
talking to crowds like this a Mercury
and
at almost every
speech I gave
this group these groups of women and
they were different at every place
we'd come and sit in the front row
before they show up early
and then when I was getting when I
finished they'd wait and they'd asked to
talk to me
and as it turns out they were all of
them
with the mothers of intellectually
disabled children
and they all believe that the vaccines
had caused their child's injury
particularly Mercury vaccines
and
they would say to me in a very
respectful but also kind of vaguely
scalding away
if you're really interested in Mercury
exposures to Children you need to look
at vaccines
I didn't want to do it
I had spent a lot of my life working on
the issues of intellectual disabilities
I was raised was part of the DNA of my
family my aunt Eunice was also my
godmother started Special Olympics
I had been working in Special Olympics
was then called Camp Shriver
since I was eight years old every
weekend as a hugger as a coach
I spent 200 hours as a teenager I in
high school working in what I say I come
for the my my family my uncle
was chair of the health committee for 50
years my family wrote a lot of the
legislation that gave rights and changed
the entire relationship with the with
individuals with intellectual
disabilities the most vulnerable
population in the country but I didn't
want to do that for my life
I wanted to work on Fisheries on water
pollution on energy
and so I was dodging these ladies
and then one of them
one of them came to my house
found my house on Cape Cod
and um
in the summer of 2005
she was a psychologist from Minnesota
named Sarah Bridges
she had a son who got severe autism from
a Mercury vaccine he had gotten
a 20 million dollar award from the
vaccine Court which recognizes autism
came from the vaccine who has no
controversy and she didn't want it to
happen to other children and she showed
up at my house
and she took out of the trunk or a stack
of studies about 18 inches deep
she put it on my front front stoop and
she knocked on the door
and when I came to the door she pointed
to the pile and she said I'm not leaving
here until you read those
and
I uh I I'm accustomed to reading science
I wanted to be a scientist when I was a
kid
and my
um my the kind of law that I practice
involves a lot of science so almost
every suit that I brought
has involved some kind of scientific
controversy
and I would not be better very good at
my job if I didn't enjoy reading science
and if I could not read it critically
and so I sat down and I didn't read the
studies but I read the abstracts
and I got about six inches down on that
pile
and I was just dumbstruck
by this huge Delta
between what the public health agencies
were saying the science said
and what the actual peer-reviewed
published science was saying
and I started after that doing what I
always did when I didn't understand
something I had because of my name and
my family's relationships
with these agencies I could always get
the head of an agency on a phone very
quickly and I started calling them and
asking questions I got Francis Collins
from NIH and Kathleen Stratton and Marie
McCormick from Institute of medicine and
they told me something weird I asked
them about science and I realized they
were completely not conversant with it
they were just
parroting this phrase safe and effective
I hadn't read any of the actual science
and when I asked them about details they
said you have to talk to Paul often
well Paul offered is a vaccine developer
who's a partner of mercks
and you know I had been working with it
with EPA for many years suing about
probably 20 of my losses were against
EPA which is a captive agency but
opted by the oil and chemical and
pesticide Industries
and
um you know
EPA if I if I call a science guy or a
regulator there they're going to have
some self-respect
and they're going to try to answer my
question they're not going to direct me
to a coal industry lobbyists
so this was bizarre and and when I
talked up all of it
I I caught him in a lie
like uh and which I'm not going to go
into I'd love to go into but I'm gonna
um I I need to conserve my time here so
take my word for it and but he knew I
caught him in the lie I knew and there
was that moment where we're like you are
just a liar
and uh and uh and oh so then uh
then I realized okay these guys either
don't know what they're doing or they're
lying about it deliberately and then I
realize these agencies were completely
captured by the agency capture on
steroids FDA gets more than 50 of its
budget from the pharmaceutical companies
CDC is a 12 billion dollar budget and
five billion of that's almost half goes
to buying vaccines from these companies
and then distribute them so if you work
a CDC
you do not get promotions
by finding problems with vaccines you
get promoted by increasing uptake
and um and then NIH
is just an incubator pharmaceutical
product so it develops the vaccines
hands them over to the industry it hands
them over to the universities
which then get NIH money 200 300 million
dollars to do phase two and phase three
phase one and phase two trials
and if those are successful which they
always are because they make them
successful
they then call in the pharmaceutical
company to do a phase three
and then they all divide up the royalty
but the patent marching rights and then
they all go you know then Tony faucially
agent walks it through the regulatory
process at MTA and CDC where he's picked
the members of the panels who are all
taking money from him
and they know their product that snacks
in line
and their job is to rubber stamp this
product and recommend it to children
oh I saw this this process and how it
worked and um it's behind you know it
was regulatory capture on steroids it
was like and then NIH gets the money I
got the platform
for saying NIH owns half this fact the
modern vaccine
they said that's vaccine misinformation
well guess what on Thursday this week
moderna made a 400 million dollar
payment NIH for his to share the
royalties to date
so
um you know all of my conspiracy
theories about a three-month shelf life
before they become reality
and
[Applause]